the sun's just come up here for a second
day and since this tornado revealing the
utter scale of Destruction here it's
almost eerily silent aside from the
occasional chirping of birds occasional
cars passing many people taking videos
and pictures local people from
surrounding towns amazed at the
jaw-dropping level of damage this was an
extremely violent tornado bringing winds
around 165 to 200 miles per hour and in
practice what that meant was that
anything in its path was completely
pulverized will just pan round here as
you mentioned I'm in Rolling Fork
Mississippi which is the worst affected
town across Mississippi and Alabama as
you said at least 26 people dead and the
search going on for survivors although
much of that is a recovery operation as
they seek to bring bodies from the
wreckage
this structure that you see behind me
all the remains of this structure a
brick building completely leveled uh
this was Chuck's Dairy Bar a diner which
is the photo was the focal point of life
in this town and it stayed open late
into the night so it was open at around
8pm on Friday evening when this tornado
came through and the people who were
here many of them enjoying an evening
meal they didn't get much warning there
was a text alert minutes before this
tornado hit advising them
urgently to take cover but clearly not
long enough to try and find tornado
shelters so they tried to Shield
themselves in whatever way that they
could and that's where these remarkable
Tales of survival come in and you can
see just beyond these cars which were
tossed onto the top of the building
there's a gray Cube structure in the
background it's actually the walk-in
refrigerator of Chuck's Dairy Bar and it
was here that the the two owners of
Chucks and a few customers who were here
they hid in the refrigerator and the
owner tells this incredible story that
as he was shutting the door wrestling
against This ferocious wind he could see
the sky from above so it had already
ripped off the roof of this building
I'll just walk around here to give you a
sense of just how
utterly destroyed Rolling Fork
Mississippi as you can see
here a few of the the chairs remaining
cars toss all over the place and in the
background there this was Chuck's Motel
so sort of a hotel type thing completely
leveled there is usually around 2 000
people living in Rolling Fork many
hundreds of them have been left homeless
you can see here very very little in
this town has been left untouched and so
that's where the the operation is at the
moment to try and get these people
shelter and food and water because much
of the water supply in this area is
contaminated too you can see
trees 50 year old trees ripped from
their Roots completely shown of their
leaves it really is quite incredible
um just how little This Tornado has left
behind but what's also a amazing is just
how concentrated this destruction is
while Rolling Fork has been completely
leveled there's a village less than a
three minute drive away which is
completely untouched and that's just how
this tornado has operated it it's um
plotted its path through here and even
though it's covered an area of over 100
miles its path is very selective so this
recovery operation ongoing but it
clearly there's a complete rebuilding a
Rolling Fork if that ever takes place
that needs to be done very very little
remaining here the search still ongoing
for survivors